well you know we're very lucky to have a
lot of healthy sunshine here in the
desert many areas of the country stuck
with gray and cold weather this time of
year sherry yeah millions of people and
mostly women in those gloomy climates
suffer from something called seasonal
affective disorder or sad and you may
know someone whose sunny personality
changes this time of year here's how to
recognize the mood disorder and ways to
help conquer it
for a lot of people having seasonal
affective disorder could you know feel
like you're you know experiencing
fatigue you know loss of interest you
know activities difficulty focusing
jacob cooper is a new york clinical
social worker who says sad is more
complicated than just having the winter
blues it's not necessarily so much the
coal that does impact it but the
decreased sunlight you know impacts our
own serotonin levels which is that feel
good hormone as well as our melatonin
which you know regulates sleep you know
patterns the mood disorder can start as
early as the fall when daylight saving
time ends and the days grow shorter into
winter cooper says the lack of sunlight
and color can alter a person's brain
chemistry leading to depression loss of
appetite and poor sleep seasonal affect
disorder very much has to do
with our own bio neuro chemistry so how
do you combat sad and trigger healthy
happy brain activity this time of year
experts say increase your exercise
put more proteins in your diet take away
the alcohol and sugar
practice meditation or yoga to reduce
anxiety and add light lamps which mimic
sunlight and help regulate our body's
circadian rhythm and even they make
these alarm clocks with light therapy
when you wake up so you know if you're
in a place without a lot of light you're
able to have this light therapy when you
wake up so your day is off to a good
intention cooper also recommends
holistic therapies like amethyst
crystals salt lamps and essential oils
that can lift a person's spirits during
a dark time of year you know small
things that we kind of like put on the
bookshelf and say as we will you know
try it out and see the difference that
it has in your life you might be
surprised
they were called wu-wu but that was his
term
it is cooper says the salt lamps put out
negative ions which is similar to
connecting with nature he also says if
the depression or sleep disruptions are
serious psychotherapy can often help or
you may need to consult your doctor so
he he or she can prescribe a medication
as a last resort so i think we
some of us have lived in great climates
uh seattle areas one a lot of folks in
the midwest this time of year
if you have relatives that live there
and you notice their personalities
change a little bit could be that they
suffer from seasonal affective disorder
we're lucky that we have so much good
sunshine here even in the winter but it
doesn't change the fact that it can
still you can still have those emotions
even in las vegas where it's sunny you
know most of the time if not all the
time it is still something that like
this time of year that's why i try and
hike as much as possible if there's not
as much sunlight maximize the sunlight
that we do have because the days are
really short and the nights are really
long and if you work in a building with
without windows you don't get to see a
lot of sunlight during the day maybe you
come to work before the sun is up what
do you say exactly wait what
after the sun goes down
so there you go it's some good
information